next speaker is mark venials mark is
mark can you
share your screen please
yeah so mark is a post doc currently uh
at the
simons um and before that
he was uh working in
the technion he's a visiting fellow at
technion
uh with you all filmis and he did his
phd
with under jakob nordstrom at the kth
uh in sweden uh and without further ado
mark the floor is yours
uh right thank you vijay so
yeah keeping with the topic of the
workshop i'm going to talk about
how we can use proof complexity to talk
about solvers
and this time we're going to go really
really deep into the gods of the solvers
and talk about the actual heuristics
being used in the solvers
so let me quickly recall our beloved
cpcl algorithm
which is based on dpl from the 60s so
in dpl we
have a formula and we branch on
variables if there's a unit
variable we propagated if there's a
conflict then we backtrack
so in this example we would branch an x
branch in y then get a conflict with z
back track and so on now
the change that ctcl introduces is that
we can learn
process so
for instance here at the first conflict
we are able to
learn that constraint y must be true and
now that's great
because when we backtrack past x
and now this time because we have
already this clause we can use it and we
can
avoid having to traverse part of the
search tree
again okay
uh so now let's get proof complexity
into the picture and this is actually a
kind quite easy thing to do it's enough
to look
at the cdcl execution trace and just
reverse all the arrows
so while we had arrows pointing in the
direction now we
reverse them and we get a perfectly
valid resolution proof
now because this is cdc and we have
learning we're also
going to have some arrows that come from
previous parts of the search tree
into further parts of the first tree
like here
so the proof is not going to look like a
tree it's going to look like a general
directly specific graph instead
and in fact this is what distinguishes
csl
and dpl in the proof complexity world
so while dpl only produces proofs that
look like a tree
so that would be three like resolution
cdcl produces
a more general kind of proofs and since
we know that
three-legged resolution is weaker than
resolution then we
can say huh this is a great reason for
why
c vcls work better than the pll
and of course the question still remains
whether cdcl is
as powerful as general resolution or
is it maybe some just some subset of
that like the pillar
is this is a question that was
investigated during the early 2000s
and it was answered in december 2009 by
this couple of papers
showing that yeah cdcl proofs are
roughly equivalent to resolution proofs
at most
up to some polynomial factor difference
that however the result however needs
just to make a few assumptions on the
model
we have to assume that we are using
optimal choices of variables we have to
assume that we don't throw away clauses
we have to assume that solver restarts
frequently enough
and we also have to assume that the
learning
scheme is a reasonable one such as first
yt
but let's just focus on the theorem
itself
we have that cvcl can efficiently find
resolution proofs
now susana told us that
that's uh impossible if
p unless p is different from uh
let me phrase that um if there was a
there were a deterministic algorithm
that could officially find
from proofs then p would be equipment
so what's going on here well that's of
course because of the um
when the the solver makes choices this
result that cdcl can efficiently find
resolution proofs
uh to work we need to have an oracle
that every time that the solver wants to
branch
to fix the value of a variable uh the
solver would ask
this oracle okay please tell me a
variable now it will branch on that
variable
and so on and it has to do that every
time that it wants to
to decide the variable now this is of
course a
strong assumption we can weaken it for
instance if we have
random decisions then we can have a
similar result saying that now cdcl can
simulate
not resolution but bounded with
resolution which is a smaller class
that's
quite important but then what happens
if we go and plug in here not
optimum decisions not random decisions
but the kind of
heuristics that solvers would use in in
the real world
well then we no longer have
a simulation we in fact have that cvcl
and resolution are exponentially apart
so more precisely there's there are
formulas
that have resolution refutations that
are
short just volume in length but
if we want to find out that they are
unsatisfiable
using cdcl that would take exponentially
long time to do
as long as we're using this common
powerful decision every students
so so mark this is more like a
non-automatability kind of result
under the assumption that the branching
heuristic is
um visas
is that fair exactly so yeah so while
the result of
tells us that non-automatizability
if you assume p versus np this tells us
the same but
assuming these heuristics instead
so it's um the result that doesn't
depend on p versus np
but it's limited not to any algorithm
but only to the cdc
with these universities yeah thanks
visit
uh great well let's talk about the
decision first with
more depth
and so we are at this part of the solar
where we want branch in a variable
and we're trying to answer this question
please actually now going fixed
and it's really not obvious what
what a good literal would be that's why
we had to assume an oracle before
um what solvers try to do
currently or at least an explanation for
what they are trying to do
is that it seems that the good idea is
to pick literal that will quickly lead
us to a conflict
so we would like to avoid having to do
many propagations many further decisions
so as if we can get to conflict as soon
as possible then we're happy
and the way to try to achieve that is to
pick
a variable that has been involved in a
conflict recently with the hope that
yeah
if it's if it was involved in a conflict
when we're probably
in a part of the search speech that is
close to that then chances are that
we'll get a another conflict soon
and this is how the visits heuristic
works so
we give a score that's a real number to
each variable
i initially scored zero and now every
time that we hit a
conflict we if a variable has been in a
conflict
then we increase its score by one and if
it hasn't
been in a conflict with or nothing and
now and then we multiply
all the scores by some number that's
less than one so that they decay
in time so this is just implementing an
exponential
moving average function and when we want
to pick a variable we just go and pick
the variable that has the largest score
about the sign here it's usually
combined with the phase saving heuristic
where we
assign the variable to the same polarity
that
was last assigned the last time that we
saw this variable in the trade
right let me make another observation
about visits um
let's think what happens when we have a
variable that
is in a conflict then it's core it's
always going to be positive
it first gets increased by one
and then it gets it's done but it stays
positive
while a variable that has never been in
a conflict
always has score zero so that means that
the variable that has been in a conflict
is always speak before apartheid that
never has
now this true in theory
may be not so true in practice so
if we assume that we have unbounded
precision numbers
the scores have infinite precision and
they're real numbers
then this is true if we implement them
with doubles
then it might be that a variable is in a
conflict and then a lot of time
there's a lot of time in between the
conflicts and
the the score might decay to a number
that's so small that we cannot represent
it
and it uh then gets rounded down to zero
and then what happens depends a lot on
on the exact implementation of the
solver
so if the solver uses a stable data
structure where
numbers with the same score are not
rearranged
then we're still this observation is
still true
if it has another kind of data structure
then it might not be true
but uh again things start to get messy
so we're going to just assume that the
observation holds for now
great uh i want to give you now a bit of
uh an idea of how we could try to
or try to build the formula that has
these properties that it's easy for
resolution but
hard for visits and
yeah let's start with the first thing
you could think of
uh let's just have two formulas one
that's easy
one that's hard we of course want to
have a formula that's easy
because that'll be an easy short proof
uh and it seems that it would be a good
idea to have a formula that's hard
because we want to trick the solver into
solving that
hard format um
yeah just for the
[Music]
proof complexity experts uh think of
this heart formula as an exponential
formula required in exponentially long
proofs such as
anyway so let's see that the solver
starts talking about some variables in
the hard part
like here um and reaches a conflict
then these variables have their scored
score increased and that is going to
lead us to more conflicts in the hard
part so we're
doing well that's what we want to happen
but uh this hard formulas
have a very global structure so
once you if you only assign a few
variables
then it's it's always possible to find
the satisfying sign
so what's most likely going to happen is
that after
a couple of clicks now the
the current assignment will be
satisfying the hard part
and then the server is again free to go
and choose any literal that it wants and
maybe now
it will start talking about the easy
part
reach some conflicts over there and
very very quickly go and solve the easy
part so that's
that's not what we want
okay then let's try to make life
harder for the software
and we're going to add some more closest
now
um so specifically crafted gadget
just a set of crosses with the following
property that
when the solver starts assigning
variables from the gadget then suddenly
we'll start
unit propagating and start talking about
all the formulas in the
hard part of the variables in the heart
part of the formula
and after it's on that and it's talked
about all these variables
then it will reach a conflict so now
that's awesome
because all all of the variables
in the hard part of the formula have now
positive score
so score one at least
and now the next conflict will have
necessarily have to involve
variables from the hard part because the
score is positive
the next conflict also will have to do
that and so we'll have the next conflict
and of course there might be some
variables that
that are elsewhere in the formula but
since their score is still positive
the solver is now stuck here it's it
must always be
variables from the hard part of formula
and because we know that so that the
solver will
end by proving the that the heart
formula is false
and because we know that there's an
exponentially long proof of that
or rather that all proofs must be
extremely long
this tells us that to find that proof
the solver must have taken exponentially
long time
now this is uh almost uh it
there's only one small thing that
we still have a small but uh non-zero
probability
of solving the easy part first right
this was true if the solver started
talking about the fitful gadget
but maybe it starts talking about the
easy part and what do we know
so in order to fix that we can also add
a few more
clauses that will
make the solver so when it starts
talking about
the easy part it will automatically
shift its attention to the faithful
gadget
and then we are in good shape because
the big four gadgets will propagate
and all the previous reasons were told
now to talk about this the only thing
that we
used about the heuristic was really this
property that
a variable that's been in conflict will
always be picked before a variable that
has never been in a contract
and this is a property that not only
visits us but
all most of the heuristics currently in
use
have this property so vargo moves the
front visits cgb
lrb all of them has its property
and and they will be tricked by this
kind of formula
also the results hold the
real holds no matter whether you have or
you don't have restarts
but interestingly it doesn't hold if you
clear
the the score of the variables when you
restart
and uh ian is going to talk about more
about this in a while
now you might be thinking yeah yeah this
was some theoretical work
and looks
very theoretical but what can you tell
me about this in practice
well let's see some data um
so here in this table we have four
solvers
each with the with a different heuristic
so vntf is it chp lrb
plus a fifth uh solver that uses
uh an oracle so it's a
finely tuned first
and now in each of the rows
so i have two formulas one
one instance of just the hard part so
the the the big
red scary part
uh one of size 45 on size 50 and they
are chosen so that the first one
is hard to spot but can still be done
within an hour
while the second one is just a bit
and cannot be solved within an hour
and that's just impossible it it can
never
be square because it's just hard there's
no matter how we try
any solver using resolution we'll never
be able to solve this
while if we look at this tricky example
so there are two formulas here the first
one is based on the first half formula
the second one is based on the
second formula now what happens
is that it stays roughly equally hard
um for for the normal kind of solvers
but now of course
we know that this formula does have a
short proof so it's pos it's possible to
find
a great decision heuristic that's finely
tuned to this formula and
makes the solver run fast and indeed by
doing that
then we can solve this formula in less
than one second
just it's that easy
anyway um so let me finish by saying
that
so while we think of cdcl being
equivalent to resolution
that's only the non-deterministic
version of cbcl and we should keep in
mind that
with the actual heuristics that's not
necessarily the case
[Music]
and some problems so
i mentioned that the result is dependent
on whether
you have arbitrary precision or fixed
precision would be great to manage to
prove this
with uh limited precision like solvers
have in the real world
the construction is also a bit clunky
and
i i didn't even there to show you all
the clauses it
just it wouldn't make sense so it would
be nice if we could
simplify this construction a bit and
then it would be great to improve visits
i don't think
that we should throw away visits or any
of these other heuristics that they
really really work great um
but it's also true that there is room
for for improvement
so of course we could try to learn the
lesson from
from here and and improve the
seriousness
so thanks thank you mark for a fantastic
talk
uh yeah it was wonderful um
i was wondering if there are any
questions before i ask mine
so dmitry has a question uh it says
is there any satisfiable formula that is
probably hard for cdco
with some heuristics mark
[Music]
uh i know some certainly results from
malach
no uh dmitry ian is going to talk about
it actually
but there the idea would be yeah
sorry yeah i left
here here and the saxon gave an example
for the pll
soldiers um what i'm asking is there
anything
similar from for cdca yeah
yeah so there is a talk uh in 20 minutes
yeah my student ian will talk about
exactly such formulas
but they're the heuristic that we switch
on and off is restarts not
not uh
uh so uh mark uh i think
some of the work in improving visas that
you're referring
to one of the things that your work
suggests is
kind of refocusing the branching
heuristic at regular intervals
not necessarily zeroing out the activity
but maybe
one way to refocus the term refocus here
means as you well know
across restart boundaries we maintain
the activity heuristics
we don't throw them away and usually
it's not a good idea to throw the
activity
of the variables but perhaps it may be a
good idea to change the activity of the
variables through some
some heuristic and i think that might
be uh that heuristic where you refocus
the activity could be tested against
your class of instances
to see whether it helps solve those
instances
more efficiently yeah yeah exactly
and we do know that if you
if you do this throwing away the
activity then the solver will run fast
from these instances
right but of course we don't want to do
that right so we want to find that
balance where we
do along your instances but also on
uh set competition or verification
instances
anyway this was a great talk thank you
so much mark